hey guys welcome back to a brand new
video and today's gonna be a little bit
different I ended up collabing and
teaming up with spliced and we did dual
gameplay for gladiator on the new dance
of death mode so me and him end up
playing gladiator faced a couple matches
if you want to go check out his version
we did do four matches I got the last
two he got the first two so you're gonna
be seeing new gameplay regardless of who
you're checking out I'll leave his
channel and the video in the description
if you want to go check him out he's
really good if you haven't heard of
spliced he's really good at for honor he
does a lot of gameplay with a lot of the
characters mainly lob ring or Centurion
a lot of those characters he's an
incredible player so definitely go check
him out but that guys hope you guys
enjoyed the video hope you guys have a
great rest of your day and peace out
all right here we go wreck 18 each get
ready to parry those top plates Minh
can't wait to get I can't wait to get
soon
[Music]
you know Gordon can't do anything on his
on his shoulder bash cuz I could just
you could just punch out of it the roach
is ready I think I just knock the warden
off the map
ok I can't no I almost got it I did not
expected me to do that I'm just I'm just
gonna I'm just gonna wait warden Bryan
you go for it go for it ok
oh he's gonna oh yes I got it
anymore that was close that was close
we're both cops I stamina that wasn't
bad that wasn't bad and he the warden
only died once so you almost got a like
first time to the wardens not too bad
it'd be just shoulder rashes you could
just punch him with the buckler and
you'll get out of the way of it yeah
it's the exact same with uh with shamans
side heavy he can't guard break you from
it
no pop lights
okay Ward's ready Road she's got a
behalf
I got he's not a stamina but I'm trying
he really loves these top lights Hiero
cheese about one hit so you want to go
yeah
all right let me try to get the guard
brick I got the girl break okay
I'm me too perfectly we gonna keep all
three like backs up and he like backs up
and I'm like slices you from the side no
whatever
oh yeah that's from Russia did you let
that rip cuz he's like rep one probably
won't guess it or somebody I think the
other one is ripped tired or something
yeah I mean Joni subbu
oh my god that was nice what is it again
if you block the board and zone its
recovery
yeah all right yes making sure he left
he liked to vote I'm dad named clam a
wardens super low he's doing a long
execution I got plenty of time
wardens out of stamina with a barb isn't
him okay he's barely hitting me he's
coming towards you all right that's fine
if the ball hit me yeah that warden is
not doing so hot
there we go execution no oh there we go
perfect actually worked bad place GG oh
is this map okay oh I'm probably gonna
get baseball banded if I fight that
should I'm on the sugar giving up I'm on
the Raider
what was the thing for reader were like
you get guard break him through if he
does his own yeah if you're on the
ground when he does max punish you can
guard break after okay she go get a
little bit almost ready now Raiders
about a little bit more than a half he's
playing really thoroughly okay I'll just
I'll just stay close yeah watch the nose
the like the toast I don't know if he
just guessed it coming or something but
he's been dodging most of my toast ebbs
okay [ __ ] dude
I'm dad mistake he gotten out of stand
when I hit on me rip he's coming towards
you alright oh whoops executing go for
it oh come on what timing
damn that time I thought it was uh I
thought it was within range yeah he's
playing he's been pretty too early no
we've killed the Raider by accident
parry
[Music]
on the radio I know I should go if he's
gonna be revenge in Tibet oh no oh no
I'm dad oh that was close [ __ ] zone
cancel they're both super okay ready
ready go they're all perfect it looked
it right away from me
nice who's focused on you the Shikoku is
just a walking fortress yeah
did I can't fight Raider man that that
stunning tap to zone and then cancel it
back into another stunning tap gets me
every single time
no really I can't I can't see oh yeah
yeah it's me every time I look in the
little tiny like little tiny bit of you
that I have to just see if he does an
animation change and I know hmm from
that point this is guard break can get
rid of shougo keys hyper armor yes so
okay
that was super delayed shougo keys one
bar I'm still over half just keep your
distance from of it yeah he tried to
demons embrace me for that max I'm not a
stamina in a minute he's really going
for the demons embrace right now he's
he's run to you watch out okay
Vader's got revenge oh that's gonna kill
me I'd am barely hit the wall he's
Raiders around you didn't like yeah
minimis name back to you I forgot the
sugar cheese not done I'm gonna take
demon brace I can't do anything with her
that the reason I don't set free girl
Gracie damn I'm gonna the wall
I could Perry I'm really weak Rena yeah
so am i I'm like super I'm dad I'm dad
say left damn back I don't know all
perfect okay I don't know why I went
that way this is great this is great
he's gonna demons embrace watch out for
the weather for the Shikoku right he's
gonna get revenge damn boo
she'sshe's gonna throw me off Oh Oh a
nice perfect
look at that carried GARP shoo go keys
uh shoo go Keys really crazy yeah kind
of just went for the kill on she go key
cuz I didn't wanted demons embrace me
when I was in a fight so yeah that's the
thing that's that's really worrisome
with Asha go key man we don't pay
attention to him he will grab you man
yup Oh he'd almost throw me off though I
just saved me kind of I'm just taking
that in my car breakdown like an idiot
got me off the edge damn dude um oh wow
demons embrace saving me I felt pretty
good I'm getting really long oh I got
the long execution I'm back I'm gonna
take some demon
I'm getting thrown to well we're getting
tossed around it yep still winning
though [ __ ] why did I do that I knew
that was coming too
I'm one shot so I'm like damn it should
go key went right through you you see
that the heavy would have hit him yeah
or to kill them damn man I don't do too
great need a little bit more HP for that
I have like the two characters I can't
fake I can't face however for Rader
keeps mixing me up and I'm falling for
it every time
I'll take care of the Raider then
shikoku just had two away from to do
lights
you just pair you
all right radios ready should go keys a
little bit more than half there we go
just kind of alone already
damn dude constant head butts I'll let
you do the guard break and then I'll go
for the kill
[Music]
he's about two bars okay it's that high
problem and I'm just rigorous getting uh
shoe cookies run into you oh [ __ ] no no
no okay just stay alive just say live
[ __ ] again am should've seen that
coming he went on the bridge I tried to
tow stab just gotta break me damn it
got off the edge
whoa what just happened there
what's happening I don't even know I
[Music]
don't know how you fought this Raiders
being super totally right now I'm gonna
get him she wasn't too totally to me
yeah that was guaranteed okay that's fun
I'm alive still oh I'm dead doing long
execution I come back he's he's weak
because he diamond yep
Raiders super low okay oh I got the edge
I'm back
are you kidding me am I going I'm going
off to a damn that's okay ready to come
off screen I'm back oh there we go okay
here we go
gotta get the guard break gotta get the
Garber yeah all Raiders are on the way
doing it raw and she's really being
totally with this on no you don't time
you don't I'm just leave it yeah go get
this go key oh they're both run to me I
killed the that's final weight of accent
I can see I'm gonna kill the Raider all
right they're coming
I should go keys four and a half okay
all right here we go
oh no yeah that's okay that's okay I'm
spawning right next to you though oh wow
he tried to hit me go for it
I can't yeah I can't I'm most I'm gonna
just wait all right okay go go I got I
got I got it oh that was pretty hard
that's shikko key I was so worried cuz
he kept doing the demons embrace Musil
oh yeah cuz I don't want to get him well
I sucked horribly that game yeah it's
the team win that matters yeah god damn
cuz that gave you my keep going I think
I'll be good